I love Turkish food but I've never ever
had the chance to cook it properly so
there's a first time for everything and
tonight I'm going back to the floor
inside this Turkish restaurant to be a
sous chef at the forefront of service so
I can't afford any cock-ups Kazan is one
of London's finest Turkish restaurants
with an incredibly busy dinner service
at the moment we've got about 19 booked
in I think it's going to be really busy
really tough the busy kitchen is run by
head chef Hassan
he is exacting standards and a fiery
temper sounds familiar
apparently has sounds a man not easily
impressed it's putting fire with fire
really so it could either be a big
explosion in there or or they'll get on
great hello hi how are you Hassan ooh
stir yes chef yes rooster is the boss
yes all the starters and desserts are
being prepared in advance of service I'm
going to learn three classics dolma yeah
they're vine leaves and this stuff with
herb rice after quickly been showing the
intricate technique it's my turn very
very difficult but have all them nice
and tight they're gonna be steamed after
but it takes me two minutes to make one
goal one the chef's here can make one in
10 seconds quite sweet I'd love to stay
in practice but sheperson
has different ideas so inside the field
of pastry job cheese darkness cheese
feta cheese baby spinach right it's food
what's inside but this can't make him
correctly
no one can pick these skills up
immediately the chef's here take years
to perfect their techniques but only
have a couple of minutes last one is
okay I'm a you're a tough cookie to
pleaser
i Stannis take the hardest for last the
traditional desert back lava this
manager by Travis Parris yes it's all he
does at that level all day Wow
pastries never been my strong point I'm
rolling it this five takes years to
perfect just roll with service looming
has had happened a time for me to make
mistakes blimey he's got less patience
than me after rolling the sheets as
thinly as possible they're cut them
layered into a baking tin
transparent almost see-through it
clarified butter is added it goes in the
oven and will be sweetened with syrup
and nuts when cooked delicious end of
round one next up service